we were just telling you only about the
extraordinary remembrance display in
London let's also tell you now about the
classical singers Alex Jones and Russel
Watson who are collaborating for the
first time to commemorate a hundred
years since the end of the first world
war and the 70th anniversary of the NHS
the pair had recorded a song named where
have all the flowers gone to honor
servicemen and women as well as doctors
and nurses we can ever listen now
[Music]
Hooten
[Applause]
[Music]
well Russell and Alan may look like
they're auditioning for a new reading
shift but they're not yes very good ma
would look it out later thanks for
coming in chaps and talking about this
who's it aimed at who who you pitching
it towards no it's not really a pitch
it's just erm it's a commemoration of
the end of World War one and all the
lives that were lost and there were a
lot of lives lost and it's also a tip of
the hat to the heroes of the NHS in the
70th year of the NHS international
institution a tip of the hat
Aled what do you say to those people who
think hang on these are two you know
mutually exclusive things the work that
Docs and nurses do wonderful though it
is is incomparable the sacrifice of
hundreds of thousands have met I don't
agree with you to be honest with you
because you know the word hero is
bandied around quite a lot these days
you know sports people can be heroes
sometimes even singers well actually
that the tireless work the doctors and
nurses do they are actually heroes
unsung heroes and of course those people
who went to war 100 years ago and who
went to war after our heroes as well
they gave up their lives so we could
lead us you know and we're mere singers
but we wanted to go in the studio and do
our bit and these are songs that we've
never recorded before but they've been
part of our lives if you like I remember
singing you know where have all the
flowers gone when I was a kid at school
so to be able to go to the studio and
record it with Russell was such a great
experience so how did you choose the
songs involved here because let's let's
be brutally frank the songs that young
men sang as they marched the front and
oftentimes to their doom very few people
remember now they're not that household
choose that they once were
when you say brutally frank what exactly
do you make the songs the songs the
songs that the young men sang as they
marched in the front that were the songs
of the Music Hall etc of that Canon at
the time nobody particularly remembers
anymore
no no but the actual alcohol things
about remembering yeah I think that's
that's vital and that's what we're
trying to do with these two particular
songs but I would say the rest
the songs on the album are songs that
you know you would expect this to be
singing things like you raise me up
their songs that maybe we've sung when
we've been so long together yeah I never
thought I'd ever record Volare but there
we go it's done you take it you take it
out to concerts as well around the
country what have you got lined up yeah
20 dates something date 20 dates next
year yeah going England Ireland Wales
Scotland and singing this sort of music
you know they're inspirational tunes
there's also stuff like Cinema Paradiso
that neither of us have ever recorded
before and actually it's an album where
the harmonies have worked so well no one
expected our voices to gel as well as
they have and it's been brilliant it's
been a great experience and
collaborating with I'd we've been you
know pals for over 20 years
yeah he's been interviewing me
predominantly and it just seemed like a
great idea to get in the studio all
together and make some music news as
well given that you've auditioned for
the news reading shift Russell Alan
thanks both very much indeed appreciate
your time